[Music]
foreign
so we've been talking about linear
systems of differential equations like x
dot equals a x
where a is a matrix and X is a vector
and we've recently seen that it may be
possible to take a non-linear
differential equation some some truly
nonlinear differential equation x dot
equals f of x
where f is a non-linear function of X
and at least approximate it locally You
by a linear system near a fixed point so
kind of near
a fixed point
a fixed point
x bar
where f of x bar equals zero so
precisely if we have some fixed point
where D DT equals zero at that fixed
point then in a small little Epsilon
neighborhood of that point we might be
able to approximate those Dynamics
locally as a linear system
and uh I want to kind of tell you about
one really really powerful kind of idea
or theorem for dynamical systems which
gives us a lot of insight into when this
is possible and when this is not
possible and so this is called the
Hartman Groban theorem uh maybe I'll do
green because I like green
the Hartman
Hartmann
grobmann theorem
I'm not going to prove this theorem I'm
just going to give you kind of a sneak
peek of what it means for these
linearizations and when it's possible
and things like that okay so the big
idea here is that if okay so so
essentially
how do I want to say it
um
we we know even more than just we can
approximate x dot equals f of x with a
linear system we know that this a matrix
is equal to the derivative of f with
respect to X this is a matrix of partial
derivatives this is a Jacobian matrix
evaluated at
at X bar
and specifically the Hartman Groban
theorem says that
um
if
all
eigenvalues
if all the eigenvalues Lambda of a
have non-zero real part
have non-zero
real part
meaning they have the form Lambda equals
a plus or minus i b where a is not equal
to zero
these are called hyperbolic fixed points
so if all eigenvalues of Lambda of a
have non-zero real part these are called
these are called hyperbolic fixed points
called
hyperbolic I'll tell you why they're
called hyperbolic in a minute literally
it's because they have stable and
unstable directions and say they look
like you know hyperboloid points
hyperbolic points if all of the
eigenvalues are hyperbolic so we have a
hyperbolic fixed point x bar like this
then uh locally
for small neighborhood
around
X bar
then the linearized Dynamics then the
linearized
system the linearized Dynamics
given by this you know x dot equals a x
it has so we call this topological
conjugacy or topologically equivalent
but what I mean is then locally for a
very small neighborhood or on my fixed
Point these linear Dynamics are kind of
smoothly deformably equivalent to the
Dynamics of the true honest-to-goodness
non-linear system then locally for small
neighborhood around X around X bar then
the linearized Dynamics x dot equals ax
are kind of faithfully representative
uh Faithfully representative
of the full
non-linear system
I'm being intelly vague here this is a
very precise mathematical theorem and
it's it's it requires technical language
to say it very precisely and it requires
even more technical language to prove
that it's true but I'm going to draw you
a picture and tell you what I mean what
I mean is that if I have some fixed
points and maybe I'll actually draw
um you know I'll draw one in blue for my
non-linear system and let's say I over
here I linearize that non-linear system
to find this a matrix and I check that
all of the eigenvalues of this a matrix
are hyperbolic meaning they have
non-zero real parts so they all have
either a positive or A negative real
part A is either positive or negative
but not zero for all of my eigenvalues
I'm just going to draw an example so
let's say it has a a stable eigenvector
with a stable eigenvalue and let's say
it has an unstable
eigenvector with an unstable eigenvalue
so again that would be a hyperbolic
fixed point a saddle point because in
this direction a is negative and in this
direction a is positive but a is never 0
for either my eigenvalues then the
Hartmann Groban theorem says is that my
full-blown super duper non-linear system
at least near this fixed point is going
to look very very similar
structurally it's going to have the same
kind of stable and unstable Direction
coming out of it that my linearization
does now they might be curved I might
have a curved
stable manifold and I might have a
curved
unstable manifold but locally kind of
the topology of trajectories things are
going to do
saddle type things
in my system just like here in my
linearization it's doing saddle type
things okay so this is kind of neat and
there are reasons why we need this
technical theorem because it's not
obvious that the link we did a Taylor
series expansion of f of x to to
actually derive this condition for this
linearization in the last lecture and
we don't know for a fact that those
quadratic and concortic and those higher
order powers of X don't totally break
this linear behavior and cause it to do
something crazy and what Hartman
that for hyperbolic systems
small perturbations don't structurally
change the basic structure of the stable
and unstable manifolds of this
linearization so even if I add a little
Epsilon quadratic an Epsilon cubic and
Epsilon cortic to that linearization
structurally in a zoomed in window it
doesn't change the basic shape of
everything and if I zoom in close enough
it'll actually look exactly like this
system so it basically gives me a
condition for when I can structurally I
can expect structural robustness of my
linearization even when I add those
small Epsilon and Epsilon squared
non-linear terms
from my Taylor series that's kind of
what Hartman Groban is saying this does
not work for Center points Hartman
growman explicitly says it only has to
work for these hyperbolic points if a
equals zero if I have a center fixed
point if my linearization has
eigenvalues plus or minus I so that my
linearization is literally just these
concentric circles in a center
when I add an Epsilon cubic to this I
could easily break this kind of symmetry
and get something that's either stable
you know a stable sink or an unstable
Source just by adding those teeny tiny
tiny tiny Epsilon arbitrarily small
Epsilon quadratic and cubic and cortic
terms and so Center points and points
that are non-hyperbolic are not always
structurally stable so this hyperbolic
points are what are called structurally
stable this is structural stability
um structural stability
for these hyperbolic points for things
like Saddles if I had something that was
a Pure Source it would remain a Pure
Source locally near that fixed point
because all of my eigenvalues would have
positive real part and it would be a
hyperbolic fixed point but these Centers
do not have structural stability and the
Hartmann Groban does not guarantee that
the non-linear system near that fixed
Point looks anything like the
linearization and this is like there are
whole really interesting classes on
dynamical systems and differential
equations that only focus on this weird
case of non-structurally stable Center
manifold bifurcations like this is one
of my favorite fields of dynamical
systems is what can go wrong for Center
directions for Center fixed points if
you you know perturb the system or
breathe on the system the wrong way how
does it break and that's really really
interesting uh in dynamical systems
theory is to understand things like
bifurcations it turns out you know as
you increase the Reynolds number of a
fluid flow sometimes you have these
bifurcation is occurring but the Hartman
grubman guarantees that for this large
class of systems where we have
hyperbolic fixed points where we have
stable and unstable manifolds and
nothing else or stable and unstable
eigenvectors and and no neutrally stable
eigenvectors then you get the structural
stability at least zoomed in close to
that fixed point away from that fixed
Point all bets are off I could have you
know this Saddle Point here and it could
you know do something funky and there
could be a fish orbit over here I mean I
was just you know having fun drawing
stuff but
away from that fixed Point all bets are
off
but zoomed into that fixed point
structurally it's going to look like the
linearization for these hyperbolic fixed
points that's the Hartman engroben
theorem and it's a huge deal in
dynamical systems and it's what gives us
it's the theoretical foundation for why
we can linearize and why we can expect
these linearizations to mean anything at
all for our non-linear systems really
really important stuff
and I'll point out a couple of things so
if sometimes I call these stable and
unstable subspaces so I will call this
like a stable
Subspace
and literally the span of all of my
eigenvectors the span
of all my eigenvectors CJs
corresponding
to stable
landages meaning for those Lambda JS my
a was negative they're stable
eigenvalues those span all of those
eigenvectors span you know I can only
draw on two Dimensions because I'm a
puny human and we can only see in really
in two Dimensions but this could be you
know there could be multiple stable
eigenvectors of a higher dimensional a
matrix those will span a Subspace where
anything in that Subspace will be coming
into the origin because it's got stable
eigenvalues
similarly the span of all of my unstable
eigenvectors form my unstable
Subspace
it's the span of all of my unstable
eigenvectors corresponding to
eigenvalues with a positive and again
that's going to be a Subspace in general
of many eigenvectors anything in that
Subspace is going to flee from the
origin and so generally what happens is
trajectories generic trajectories will
adhere they'll come in on the stable
directions and then flee out on the
unstable directions
and what's interesting the Hartman
Groban theorem also says
sorry the stable and unstable manifold
theorem which are very closely related
to the Hartmann Groban theorem say that
even in the non-linear system locally
you have these things called so if I had
a stable Subspace now I have a stable
manifold
and it's a curved version of this
Subspace span by these eigenvectors
similarly I have a unstable manifold
and what's really cool is that at that
fixed point the tangent
to the stable and unstable manifolds
agree with my stable and unstable
subspaces so my stable manifold is like
locally tangent to that to that stable
Subspace and my unstable manifold is
locally tangent to my unstable Subspace
now you know away from the origin they
can start to curve and warp and deform
but this kind of structural stability
says not only is the kind of topology
and shape
preserved for small radii zoomed into
that fixed point but even the tangent
directions are preserved which is really
really cool really really useful and you
can actually use this idea to take this
local linearization and actually
continue out and get a formula for these
stable and unstable manifolds that's
really powerful and really cool and
again this is like a whole field of
dynamical systems
um you know like every practically
sentence I'm telling you here is like a
whole lecture on dynamical systems that
you could be building up a real
intuition for these things maybe I'll
make a series on that someday this is
kind of just a teaser that fits into my
differential equations uh lecture series
maybe I'll give you a quick example of
how to find that that stable manifold or
at least I'll draw a picture of it I
think I've drawn a nice picture here for
you but what you could do is you could
essentially let's say I have a
differential equation
um
maybe I'll write it in blue something
like
x dot equals x that's clearly unstable
and Y dot equals minus y
plus x squared so this is actually a
pretty good example here this is a
saddle point linearly if I just look at
the linearized Dynamics there's a saddle
point at the origin but this non-linear
term is doing weird things to my my
stable and unstable manifold so the
linearized system here
is going to have an unstable X Direction
an unstable X Direction and a stable y
direction okay that's what the
linearized fixed point is going to look
like
and so what I claim is that the
non-linear system is going to be locally
tangent it's going to have a stable and
unstable Direction locally tangent to
those but I'm going to claim that the
unstable
man of sorry the
the the the the part that's tangent to
this uh X Vector here is going to be
curved like this
okay so there's going to be some curved
manifold here and actually I'm going to
call this this is actually going to be
called the stable uh manifold because
it's like literally what everything's
attracting onto so so it's actually
attracting on
stably to this manifold and then
trajectories are going to be carried
away on this manifold and you can solve
for the functional form of this manifold
by just literally saying it has you know
it's some y equals Phi of X that is what
this this manifold is you know y equals
Phi of X at least locally and then I can
plug this into my differential equation
I can say well okay you know y dot
equals V Prime of x x dot so I can
literally I could take a power series
expansion C naught plus C1 X plus c 1 x
squared plus dot dot dot and I can
compute fee Prime just compute its
derivative times x dot which is times x
that's one way to write this but the
other way to write it is that it also
has to satisfy the Y dot equation and so
it would also have to satisfy minus Phi
of x
plus x squared and if you take these two
expressions this this power series and
you plug it in here and here and set
them equal you're going to find
something to the effect of Phi of x
equals like one-third x squared is this
this stable manifold and so you can
actually derive uh formulas for these
stable and unstable manifolds you know
using the Dynamics and using these power
series expansions locally that's a a
pretty big industry in dynamical systems
is to actually write these things out
and actually extend these linear and uh
and the these these stable and unstable
subspaces in into manifolds pretty cool
stuff really really powerful again
that's a whole class on dynamical
systems after this class on differential
equations but something to look forward
to lots of Rich Dynamics here lots of
really cool pictures and geometry and
the Hartmann growman is probably the
most important theorem here that
connects these linearizations to
non-linear systems again only valid in
general for these hyperbolic fixed
points okay that was what I wanted to
tell you thank you
[Music]